olá pessoal meu nome é camila é
recentemente eu mergulhei no projeto bem
ousado que foi justamente lançar o livro
na verdade foi o meu primeiro livro eu
fiz isso porque eu acredito que a melhor
forma de ensinar pelo exemplo e é
justamente isso que esse livro se propõe
e também eu acredito que o conhecimento
só tem valor quando compartilhado esse
sim o objetivo principal desse nosso
livro
nos últimos meses eu andei conversando
com várias mulheres daqui de pernambuco
mulheres das mais diversas áreas
empresárias médicas advogadas pra saber
o que elas pensam sobre o sucesso ea
gente descobrir nesse tempo que as
respostas foram super diversas mas antes
é preciso explicar que esse projeto não
começou comigo apesar de ser o meu
primeiro livro ele é o terceiro de uma
série
tudo isso começou em 2004 com meu irmão
felipe quando ele lançou o primeiro
livro dessa série
ele não tinha nem 28 anos de dário e ele
resolveu que ele queria é entrevistar os
seus ídolos e ele era uma pessoa assim
atípica que os ídolos dele não era um
cantores youtuber dj e sim dirigente
daquele pernambuco ariano suassuna
francisco brennand no mm e ele foi
adepto daquela máxima lá que não sabia
que era impossível foi lá e fez com
muita coragem e conseguiu entrevistar os
maiores empresários de pernambuco e os
maiores artistas
o livro teve conheço um conteúdo
riquíssimo com histórias fantásticas
dessas pessoas e o livro fez jus ao nome
foi realmente um sucesso
só que aí nesse primeiro livro onde tem
vieram 119 entrevistados só tiveram 17
17 por cento eram mulheres
eu confesso que na época eu não não
percebe essa diferença eu deixei passar
esse detalhe porque porque eu fiquei tão
empolgada com um projeto que era uma
coisa que ninguém tinha feito antes com
o conteúdo do livro que essa disparidade
passou despercebida a quem passou
despercebida mesmo e aí passou o tempo
muitos anos depois em 2016 felipe
resolveu reeditar o livro só que dessa
vez ele quis fazer com a pegada
diferente só com líderes empreendedores
e aí ele escolheu
sim em mais uma vez a gente se deparou
com o mesmo problema
14 por cento eram mulheres e aí eu disse
no meu deus como é que pode o que está
acontecendo é dessa vez me incomodou
bastante então conversei com eles felipe
que está acontecendo ele não é nada
machista
ele é super jovem moderno é nossa mãe
inclusive uma figura super forte então
não fazia sentir esse número e aí ele
explicou que isso retrata um pouco a
realidade que a gente vive que o livro
foi feito através de indicações através
de indicações que conversava com a
pessoa que indicavam a outra e assim foi
informado mas ele também se incomodou
com esse número quando ele viu
tá e aí eu comecei a pesquisar na
internet vos por que ser assim mesmo
essa não era ou não nossa realidade
e aí eu vi que nós mulheres somos 31%
das empreendedoras do brasil e que nós
somos responsáveis financeiramente por
mais de 40% dos usuários brasileiros
então realmente não tava essa realidade
não estava sendo bem retratada é isso
incomodou tanto a mim quanto à filipe
quanto a nossa primeira guarda que se
juntou hoje ea gente resolveu fazer
alguma coisa em relação a isso então
resolvemos fazer um livro exclusivo com
mulheres com o intuito de homenagear as
mulheres pernambucanas e contar a
história delas aqui em pernambuco nós
temos mulheres fantásticas com histórias
incríveis empreendedoras médicas
advogadas artistas enfim não falta não
faltou e não falta a história de um
jeito interessante aqui pra contar e aí
em 2007 nesse ano a gente resolveu
lançar o livro somente com mulheres com
essas mulheres que inspiram nesse
projeto conversando com essas mulheres
eu descobri que o sucesso nessa palavra
sucesso pode ter vários significados né
os mais diversos possíveis para muitas
delas significa paz realização
felicidade equilíbrio o autoconhecimento
então as respostas variaram muito de
entrevistados para entrevistadas
só que a gente percebeu também que no
começo a gente sente um certo
preconceito com essa palavra a um livro
sobre o que sucesso não quero não aí
porque porque muita gente assim como eu
associava a palavra sucesso apenas a
poder status dinheiro fama
o é não que o sucesso não seja isso né
mas o sucesso não é apenas isso é muito
mais do que isso mas assim é importante
deixar claro que a ideia do projecto
nunca foi definir o que é sucesso
nosso objetivo é muito mais ampla do que
é isso o que a gente quer que a gente
que desde o início é justamente fazer
uma ponte para ligar as mulheres que
tenham as mulheres que tem o que ensinar
com as mulheres que querem aprender é a
definição em si nem era o mais
importante então longe de uma visão
acadêmica ou de um estudo científico a
gente queria colocar os leitores perto
dessas mulheres inspiradoras era trazer
essa história pra perto dos leitores
as entrevistadas elas abriram suas vidas
contam suas histórias seus fracassos
dificuldades e colocaram isso à
disposição da gente então é um conteúdo
riquíssimo que vale a pena realmente ser
compartilhado
e aí como a gente teve acesso tanto ao
livro dos homens os dois livros
anteriores de filipe que a gente
mergulha profundamente leu releu
entendeu bem a gente também tem acesso à
internet e da mulher dele fez uma
pesquisa e a gente concluiu que tem
muitas semelhanças entre os homens de
sucesso e as mulheres de sucesso que são
características em comum os dois se não
achar graça porque é meio óbvio que são
disciplina dedicação esforço foco
determinação e garra e isso é meio que
um lugar comum é a gente sabe que todo
mundo que tem sucesso precisa dessas
características
mas nem foi isso que acho importante o
que eu quero trazer pra vocês é o que a
gente percebeu diferente
as diferenças que a gente percebeu entre
os homens e as mulheres que foi o que me
encantou na verdade nesse projeto
a gente percebeu que as mulheres elas
não têm medo de falar dos seus fracassos
tá elas entendem elas entendem que o
fracasso muitas vezes não aponte para o
sucesso
as mulheres são muito humildes em contar
quantos dificuldade não passaram para
chegar onde chegaram elas abrem seu
coração contando que tiveram que pedir
emprestado para a mãe ou pai para banco
pra agiota que quebraram não sei quantas
vezes que passaram mais de cinco anos
sem ter lucro das empresas
então a gente eu não percebi pelo menos
isso no livro dos homens essa
sensualidade essa humildade e assim elas
têm orgulho realmente de contar que
passaram pelo fracasso para chegar o
sucesso eu achei fantástico
é também e elas são muito gratos às
mulheres elas agradecem agradecem a
família ao marido e aos parceiros a todo
mundo que ajudou elas têm um sentimento
de gratidão muito grande
é difícil você falar com a mulher e ela
dizer ah eu meu sucesso eu sou eu tô
aqui sozinha e eu sou o máximo é
praticamente assim eu acho que nas
entrevistas
acho que 15 por cento das mulheres não
dedicaram o sucesso não dividiram o
sucesso com alguém e ela também tem um
senso de coletividade muito grande
elas entendem entendem mesmo a
importância do trabalho em equipe
elas dizem que sem a equipe ela não
chegarem onde chegaram então você
conversa com elas vocês percebem que ela
empurra elas dão muito valor ao time
a valorização da pessoa tem até uma
frase que eu gosto muito que a doutora
lina aventura que está no livro ela fala
que o egoísmo eo individualismo
enfraquecem qualquer tipo de missão que
é verdade né
é outra coisa também que eu percebi nas
mulheres que elas buscam e foi citado
várias e várias vezes em muitas
entrevistas é que elas estão cada vez
mais buscando a paz de espírito e uma
vida mais equilibrada
ela não se preocupam só em cem boas nas
suas carreiras em ganhar dinheiro em na
sua vida financeira elas querem também
com a família elas querem estar bem com
a saúde
então é você tem uma frase até aqui que
é também de roseane amorim que eu sou fã
dela que ela fala o seguinte a maior
empresa que nós temos é a nossa vida
então temos que investir nela então
essas características da mulher mostra
que além de todas que a gente citou
anteriormente que são comuns aos homens
e às mulheres elas têm todas essas que
são peculiares tenham também que eu acho
interessante que a resiliência ea
reinvenção é mulher é uma do nada contra
a mulher que vocês não conhecem que eram
corretora perde o emprego virá a
vendedora de roupa é trabalhava em um
banco perde o emprego vai fazer bolo em
casa
quebram a loja vai fazer outra coisa
então mulher não tem assessores e eu só
faço isso eu só sei se é contador só sei
se é isso não mulher faça o que tiver
que fazer e se vira e pronto ea questão
da resiliência é muito forte também na
mulher a gente sabe quantas vezes a
mulher caiu na vala
levantar porque tem que cuidar da casa
do marido dos filhos
então esse também foi o cara queixa
feminina que eu senti em várias
entrevistas é do fracasso ou sucesso as
mulheres passam por diversas situações
diferentes sabendo se adaptar e se
erguer e sem perder o entusiasmo e
alegria
tudo isso que elas fazem é de uma forma
leve
é com alegria mesmo sem ser uma coisa
pesada sofrida e por fim essa
característica
nenhum homem vai poder dizer que tenta
somente a mulher é multifuncional
consegue fazer mil coisas ao mesmo tempo
qual é a mulher que não fica falando no
celular escrever 90 televisão cuidam do
menino fazendo a unha então veio o homem
quando a gente vai falar duas coisas
eles vale pode parir só consegue fazer
uma coisa ao mesmo tempo
então realmente essa característica
sinto muito menos a exclusiva à nossa é
então é a gente tem mulher fantástica
mas assim eu não tenho dúvidas que há
pessoas com essas características também
alcance de vocês não são essas mulheres
que eu entrevistei o livro não aqui tem
mulheres desse jeito em todo canto tem
então as inspirações estão sempre bem
mais perto do que a gente imagina
entendemos a olhar tão longe e na grande
negligenciar pessoas ao nosso redor
a gente tem ídolos é fora do brasil
admiro a mulher não estou dizendo que
não são importantes mas assim aqui em
pernambuco a gente tem mulheres
fantásticas
dentro de casa a gente tem mulheres
fantásticas no nosso entorno têm
mulheres incríveis então a gente tem que
valorizar mais essas mulheres né quantos
talentos podem estar ao nosso lado ea
gente não está valorizando é isso essa
mensagem que quero passar a valorizar as
pessoas é o que todos nós podemos fazer
e aprender
nós mulheres devemos nos valorizar e
principalmente valorizar umas às outras
essa questão do porquê nós somos
incríveis mesmo mas a gente tem que
realmente ser mais unida mais amiga e
sem bola já umas às outras e
recentemente recentemente ontem eu numa
entrevista a uma mulher falar essa
palavra pra mim que eu não conhecia
sonoridade se vocês já conhecem e o
descobri agora solidária o feminino de
fraternidade
essa palavra ainda não está no
dicionário fraternidade a palavra
masculino nem sabia e sonoridade ao
feminino
a unidade ela quer dizer justamente
união empatia companheirismo não
julgamento e mandarim
ela quer dizer exatamente isso que nós
mulheres temos que nos apoiar nos
encorajassem gente zoa com as outras se
amiga e eu acho que está faltando um
pouco nas mulheres
isso não é culpa dos homens é culpa de
ninguém é da gente mesmo a gente que tem
que ser mais amiga das outras mais
carinhosa com as outras
então eu termino dizendo que com essa
palavra sonoridade e pedindo que a gente
tenha mais união com as outras e -
rivalidade
e aí pessoal brigada
[Aplausos]